congratulations to the class of 2010
etched in stone above the front door of
our Hall are the words erected for the
students that religion and learning may
go hand-in-hand and character grow with
knowledge this morning's baccalaureate
service is evidence of our continuing
aspiration in this regard welcome
welcome to this multi-phase
baccalaureate service
a man in his life a poem by a hooter ami
Clyde a man doesn't have time in his
life to have time for everything he
doesn't have seasons enough to have a
season for every purpose Ecclesiastes
was wrong about that a man needs to love
and to hate at the same moment to laugh
and to cry with the same eyes with the
same hands to throw stones and to gather
them to make love and war and war and
love to hate and forgive and remember
and forget to arrange and confuse to eat
and to digest what history takes years
and years to do a man doesn't have time
when he loses he seeks when he finds he
forgets when he forgets he loves and
when he loves he begins to forget and
his soul is seasoned his soul is very
professional only his body remains
forever an amateur it tries and it
misses gets muddled doesn't learn a
thing drunk and blind and its pleasures
and its pains he will die as figs dyin
autumn shriveled and full of himself and
sweet the leaves growing dry on the
ground the bare branches pointing to the
place where there is a time for
everything the modern Israeli poet
Yehuda ami clay is known for his
relentless criticism of what he saw as
the crippling precepts of ancient texts
his poem is one of urgency a poem about
time army High is responding to
Ecclesiastes famous words that begin for
everything there is a season a time to
live in a time to die a time to love and
a time to hate on the surface it seems
that army guy is saying that
Ecclesiastes
wrong dated and irrelevant that its
description of the seasons does not
apply to our complex world but in fact
amigas refutation revives the text his
argument breathes modern life into the
ancient words making Ecclesiastes
inescapably relevant in the end amigas
heresy is a deeply religious act in
Genesis the patriarch Jacob's name was
changed to Israel yes Tyrell meaning and
he wrestled with God and this name
becomes the name of the Jewish nation
holy texts such as these are the DNA of
Judaism but as our name Israel suggests
we are encouraged to wrestle with them
we are encouraged to argue with them the
way you might argue with a beloved but
difficult family member in spite of
indignant and exasperation we seek to
strengthen the bond out of commitment
and loyalty are meek wise message is
particularly applicable to today as we
prepare to enter a new phase of our
lives we do have the ability to deal
with ambiguity and with opposition and
we must if we run away from gray towards
black and white utopia's we will
inevitably destroy and be destroyed so
today with the help of Ecclesiastes and
RB hi I remind myself and you my friends
that we must not be afraid of the
ambiguities of life we must embrace
shades of grey we must wrestle with our
ancient texts and make them our own so
that they will guide us through these
complex but wondrous seasons
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 2010
back Lloyd service and thank you as we
all know we are living in a time of
great change in advancement but we're
also living in a time of conflict the
world continues to get smaller and our
country grows diversity grows in
diversity day by day and such times how
are we to go about as a global society
one that works for the advancement of
the human species as a whole nowadays I
know that certain individuals love to
mock and bash religion they say that
religion is the cause of most of our
ills that getting rid of religion will
solve most of our problems while I
emphatically say that they are wrong
while it's true that many have twisted
the scriptures for their own corrupt
agendas I firmly believe that the
solutions to many of our problems lie in
the core ideas that sustain our
religious traditions in Judaism the
Talmud highlights the value of human
life when it says whoever destroys of
soul is considered as if you destroy the
entire world and whoever it saves a life
it is considered as if you say the
entire world when we look at its LOM the
Quran tells us a diversity and
differences amongst peoples a part of
the Divine Plan o mankind we have
created you all out of a male and a
female that have made you into nations
and tribes so they might come to know
one another barely the nobles of you on
the side of God is the one is most
deeply conscious of him behold God is
all-knowing all aware in the end we are
all interconnected we're all here for a
reason for a purpose and we must live in
a world of mutual respect in the chaos
of modern life we tend to forget the
truly important things like love family
and caring for one another as the Quran
says again you cannot attain to
righteousness until you give to charity
from the possessions you love whatever
you give to charity God is fully aware
thereof we cannot be considered
righteous if we do not think of others
besides ourselves in an era of sexy
excessive individualism it's refreshing
to see that our traditions are pointing
us in a more noble direction for loving
God is akin to loving your fellow man as
Jesus says in the gospel of matthew you
must love the Lord your God with all
your heart or your soul and all your
mind this is the first and greatest
commandment a second is equally
important love your neighbor as yourself
the entire law and all the demands of
the prophets are based on these two
Commandments whatever we want for
ourselves we must want for others if we
seek truth and justice you must not seek
adjust for ourselves but for all people
it is important to remember that now
more than ever these values don't just
constitute the way of any one religion
but they also above all constitute the
American Way once again I thank you and
have a blessed day
Oh
leaving the comfort of our homes we came
to Barnard in Columbia a little under
four years ago many of us were unsure of
who our friends would be which
activities we would join and ultimately
who we would become after dance parties
in Brooks for our yearly holy paint
bagging sessions and realizing that I'm
a huge economics nerd most of my
questions had been answered I'm still
left wondering what it'll be like to
actually grow up for those of you who
have known me throughout the years
you've heard me joke about always
wanting to stay a kid but in a few days
time I'll have to face my fears and
become a real person one of the real
apartment and a real job who lives far
away from the world that has become our
home this campus as I embark on this
journey I keep the following passages
from the Hindu religious texts bartha
and the Bhagavad Gita in mind this world
is the field of action action therefore
is applauded here be fearless and pure
never waver in your determination or
your dedication give freely be
self-controlled sincere truthful loving
and full of the desire to serve learn to
be disciplined and take joy and selfless
acts do not get angry or harm any living
creature but be compassionate and gentle
show goodwill to all cultivate vigor
patients will and morality avoid malice
and pride then you will achieve your
destiny morality is well practiced by
the good morality however is always
afflicted by two things that is the
desire to of profit entertained by those
who covet it
and the desire for pleasure cherished by
those who are wedded to it whoever
without a flick ting morality and profit
or morality and pleasure or pleasure and
profit follows all three morality profit
and pleasure always succeeds in
obtaining great happiness as we leave
the comforts of this community we become
wholly responsible for ourselves and our
actions become all the more important I
hope you found these passages as
inspiring as I did and we'll let them
forever resonate in your minds I would
like to thank my parents for their
unconditional love and support and
especially for their guidance and
searching for these passages I am
grateful to have had the opportunity to
share this moment with you all and wish
you the best of luck in your future
endeavors and in obtaining great
happiness thank
the following passage taken from the
13th chapter of the Gospel of Matthew is
often called the parable of the sower on
that day Jesus went out of the house and
sat down by the sea such large crowds
gathered around him that he got into a
boat and sat down and the whole crowd
stood along the shore and he spoke to
them at length in parables saying a
sower went out to sow and as he sowed
some seed fell on the path and birds
came and ate it up some fell on rocky
ground where it had little soil it
sprang up at once because the soil was
not deep and when the Sun rose it was
scorched and it withered for lack of
roots some seed fell among thorns and
the thorns grew up and choked it but
some seed fell on rich soil and produced
fruit a hundred or sixty or thirty fold
whoever has ears ought to hear the
disciples approached him and said why do
you speak to them in parables he said to
them in reply because knowledge of the
mysteries of the kingdom of heaven has
been granted to you but to them it has
not been granted to anyone who has more
will be given and he will grow rich from
anyone who has not even what he has will
be taken away this is why I speak to
them in parables because they look but
do not see and hear but do not listen or
understand but blessed are your eyes
because they see and your ears because
they hear Amen I say to you many
prophets and righteous people longed to
see what you see but did not see it and
to hear what you hear but did not hear
it
here then the parable of the sower the
seed sown on the path is the one who
hears the word of the kingdom without
understanding it and the Evil One comes
and steals away what was sown in his
heart the seed sown on rocky ground is
the one who hears the word and receives
it at once with joy but he has no root
and lasts only for a time when some
tribulation or persecution comes because
of the world he immediately falls away
the seed sown among thorns is the one
who hears the word but then worldly
anxiety and the lurve riches choke the
word and it bears no fruit but the seed
sown on rich soil is the one who hears
the word and understands it who indeed
bears fruit and yields a hundred or
sixty or thirty fold the gospel of the
Lord in this parable Jesus tells us what
must become of the truth we have
received it needs to grow and be
fruitful we have to be like the good
soil eager to receive God's Word our
pursuit of the truth cannot stop here at
our Columbia graduation it must be a
lifelong search that is constantly aided
by our religious beliefs I chose this
passage because I believe it delivers a
universal message true faith bears fruit
among those fruits are social justice
community even the university itself but
without that root of faith the branches
all our efforts wither and die though it
is often difficult to talk about faith
with our peers on this campus or to
stand up for what we believe in in times
of adversity in doing so we may be
scattering seeds seeds that may bear
good fruit in the future
good morning dear graduates and guests
of all the ways I could characterize
characterize my experiences at Columbia
the one word I would use as perhaps
unlikely unlikely journeys unlikely
circumstances unlikely people but for
all that I believe we have become better
and stronger people for it I came to
Columbia from Brooklyn having had no
religious upbringing I took a work-study
job here at office of the university
chaplain hoping to make ends meet what I
found instead was a family of
administrators devoted to religious life
in the middle of urban America the
characters here were eclectic Buddhist
monks meditating in the basement of this
very building we had Muslim students
organizing campus-wide break of fasts
and also InterVarsity Christian rock and
roll the oh you sees commitment to
diversity would in many ways reflect my
own personal journey when I eventually
joined wkc rfm New York the radio
station on campus that broadcasts to all
of the tri-state area I brought with me
the same temperament and gentleness that
this very space and bodies I took a
chance at studying traditional musics
from all over the world both commercial
and obscure and it's taken me to places
that I never thought I'd end up and has
brought me back full circle home in fact
I believe it is this willingness to take
chances unlikely chances that defines
our institution we took a chance with
Amanda nejad
we took a chance with amendment protests
and for good reasons or bad what matters
is that we have grown our speaker here
today is a champion of many unlikely
forces born to a minister mother in
Missouri she became the first
african-american and youngest president
of Planned Parenthood she had obtained a
master's degree in infant care and nurse
midwifery from Columbia at a time when
it was still uncommon to do so she has
been named among the world's most
beautiful people by people and Harper's
Bazaar magazines and has contributed to
a wide range of cultural and political
topics on Oprah the New York Times HBO
and many others since 1995 she has
served on the board of trustees here at
Columbia where her advisory role aided
projects as various as mahat ins Ville
and the brain the mind brain behavior
project at the Medical School when we
first spoke I was so inspired by her
grace and civility and how close closely
she understood the pulse of this
University I hope you will feel the same
so without further ado please help me in
welcoming miss Faye Walton
thank you for that very generous
introduction and welcome to graduates on
this you're beginning commemoration and
justly deserved celebration I'm
delighted to have been asked to be the
speaker today and to share with you the
journeys that I have made and that that
of others which I hope will be an
example as you move into a world that is
less sheltered and more demanding in
which you will make decisions on a daily
basis from which this institution has
prepared you to accept and to follow in
thinking about my remarks this morning I
was reminded of a story that was of a
lesson that was given by a father to a
son and those of you have heard now my
background you might wonder if I'm not
suggesting that it should have been
given to a daughter from a mother but
we'll get to the mother in a moment but
this son was about to embark upon a long
journey and it was felt that he needed a
little bit of instruction in terms of
how he needed to see the world as he
came upon various encounters and the
father said to the Sun if you see a
donkey carrying gold don't say that it's
a golden donkey
say that it's a donkey carrying gold if
you see a donkey carrying a diploma
don't say that it's an educated donkey
it's a donkey carrying a diploma I don't
mean that to be too closely aligned with
what we're here today about but if you
see a man entering a holy city don't say
that it's a holy man it's a man in a
holy city I believe that the moral of
that lesson is to search beneath the
surface for the deeper meaning of what
is before you from the surface of my
aprea suspect that most would have
labeled me given my background as just a
preacher's daughter the deeper purpose
however of my life is in the profession
to which I chose to train now my mother
a minister I was a preacher's daughter
who my mother was the preacher in the
family my mother had the idea that I
would become a missionary but I didn't
become the kind of missionary that she
had envisioned but I did become a nurse
and as such it did not take me very far
away from the core values of my
fundamentalist teaching upbringing
teachings end up bringing over the years
it has been assumed that somehow I
feared a long way away and maybe your
own parents will think that as you make
choices in your life that you have
veered from their teachings it was
thought that maybe I was rebelling
against my religious upbringing or that
I had no religious values at all even
though I believed in my heart and my
soul that I remained close to the values
of my mother's teachings of honesty
service and standing up for my beliefs
even if it meant meant being persecuted
it was a journey that took me away from
the rigid judgments
toward the openness of compassion and
tolerance I traveled in the 50s with my
parents to tent revivals and I listened
to my mother preach night after night
right from wrong good and evil heaven
and hell and her messages were not
ambiguous they were powerful I sometimes
didn't know where my mother stopped and
where God began or where God began and
my mother stopped but just to cover and
hedge my bets I went to the altar night
after night to get saved because I
believe that every transgression could
be erased by the confession so I rushed
to the altar but somehow that saving
they never quite took much to my
mother's aggravation but I have come to
understand and to even Revere the
qualities of my mother's teachings for
now I recognize that these are the roots
of who I have become I come to
appreciate how essential our beliefs and
values to be held as an anchor in
shaping who we become as citizens and
ultimately who we are as people in my
mother's life and in her teachings the
lines were not fuzzy more powerfully
through her actions through the witness
of her actions I saw honesty loyalty
integrity respect and compassion for
others I saw diligence and perseverance
and I saw faith a nun abiding faith in
God these became the anchors for the
decisions that I make every day large
and small freedom of speech freedom of
religion are all of the traditions that
we cherish in the liberties of this
great country and so I came to cherish
those as well for they are rights that
have protected the traditions of our
ancestors as well as our country
and so no matter how strong a force
religion has been and shaping our lives
and it certainly was in my life I have
come to understand the importance of
restraint about our religion I grew up
with someone who proselytized her
religion but I believe it is important
never to impose those beliefs through
the force of law and while I implore you
to recognize the sacredness of this
freedom the inestimable value of not
being forced to bow down to the gods of
others and the uncompromising
determination that is needed to protect
this right please do not allow the
denial of our first liberty of the
worship of the faith of the god of our
faith to the V ever be the weapon of
oppression now I went off to college as
an impressionable 16 year old to prepare
for a degree in nursing I went with
unbridled idealism and as I said I see
you sitting before me today I think that
was me 40 some years ago I went with
religious convictions but they were soon
tempered by a different prism for the
first time I was faced with the earthly
conditions of life suffering and death
as I prepare to become a nurse over and
over and over again our professors said
to us that the only thing that was
really important was compassion and care
and we and those two qualities were not
to be conditioned on our personal views
every one of our patients was to be
respected and treated with dignity I
suppose we could extend that to say that
every one of our fellow citizens should
be treated with respect and with dignity
I learned to serve people just
differently than the manner in which my
mother's example of service hits
I did not need to share their moral or
religious beliefs their lives were not
the life that I had known or had been
brought into the hallmark of my
profession was to be the substance of
the care not the judgment of my life
choices are my views about my patient's
life choices my clinical experiences as
a student midwife right here in this
great institution of Columbia University
landed me at Harlem Hospital and I saw
the devastating effects of poverty
substance abuse unwanted children the
hope of a better life in the hereafter
didn't seem to be quite as compelling as
my mother had preached it and it seemed
that it was inadequate for the comfort
to comfort those in the pain of the
present the magnetic force to prevent
these circumstances from being visited
upon the women of my generation and
beyond has driven my life's work for
education her choice for prevention and
safety I came of age professionally I
came of age as an adult with doctors and
ministers and ordinary citizens I saw
the example of standing up for the
freedoms that are so important and vital
for every human being so when i look at
your world it is a world of choices that
i did not have in the 60s when i
graduated the freedom that you perhaps
take for granted rights that did not
exist we're freedoms that freed you for
self-determination those who resisted
oppression made it possible for you to
have the choices that you now enjoy in
the early 21st century will you fully
appreciate how important it is to accept
the responsibility of protecting all
that you have been
because you have an obligation to do so
good and responsible citizens is the
challenge before you I pray that you
will never forget that you are the
beneficiary of the struggles and the
sacrifices of others there's a story
that I think illustrates the importance
of the investment that we make in the
present and how it comes to be in the
future in the 1920s and it is as the
introduction to my talk today presented
me as the unlikely speaker perhaps in
many ways but in the 1920s the city of
Chicago was terrorized by the notorious
Al Capone and his associates among them
was one of the best attorneys in the
country and his name was Eddie O'Hare
they called him easy Eddie and even
though easy Eddie worked for Capone he
didn't much care for him he was
disgusted by the gangsters crimes and
flashy lifestyle and yes he equated it
with being Capone's lawyer just doing
his job one afternoon Eddie was working
in his private office and his teenage
son came in from school bloodied and
bruised and Eddie asked his son what had
caused those injuries and his son did
not respond and this happened over a few
days and so his father decided to go to
the school and secretly observe what was
happening to his son immediately up bun
stepping into the school he noticed that
his son was set upon by a group that
beat him viciously and he knew his son
was not a coward and could not
understand why he didn't fight back and
so he as would be the attitude or the
reaction of most parents decided that he
was going to intervene to protect his
son just then he heard one of the boys
saying
Capone has done so many evil things yet
your dad is helping him to get away with
it every time we see you we are reminded
of our murdered fathers uncles and
friends someone must pay for it and so
you are the one at that moment the
father determined what was right and
what was wrong in his work in the next
three years he secretly gathered
evidence against the gangster and
submitted it to the government which
helped to convict mr. Capone not for his
violent crimes but for tax evasion
shortly after this incident and shortly
after the conviction Eddie O'Hara was
gunned down but in 1946 the city of
Chicago expanded its airport and on an
autumn day in 1949 thousands gathered to
celebrate a new facility dedicated to
butch O'Hare a fallen world war hero the
son of easy Eddie and so I think that
within the story of easy Eddie is the
lesson of what our life every day should
be and the investment that we are making
in the future every day in life we will
face and we do face and you will face a
fine line be deciding what is right and
what is wrong these are precarious times
but they are also times of great
opportunity and you arrived at Columbia
there have been great strides that have
been made since you came here but
despite these straw these great strides
the games remain precarious I can't
imagine that because when you came here
we didn't have the ipod or the iPad
but there is still an unfinished agenda
the promise of a decent birth a decent
education a decent health care a decent
quality of life and a decent
compassionate death is indeed still a
promise that is denied by too many of
this country citizens you will enter a
world in which the wage gap will open
between men and women in your very first
job and if you choose to go on to become
to achieve your MBA and to become a
professional in business the gap will
not close throughout the career the gap
will remain open and so it may be harder
for you than it was for the the time of
my generation those of my generation
because you have so many more choices
and so many more opportunities to falter
but you have a privilege that carries a
great big price tag the obligation of
service and the duty of courage and
leadership your life possibilities will
expand and shrink and direct proportion
to the strength of your courage and the
investment that you make and will you be
as robert f kennedy once stated that he
sees things and looks at things the way
they are and ask why and I dream of
things that never were and ask why not
will you be challenged to be good
stewards of society of community a
family of self to navigate your personal
journey you will be challenged to
negotiate moral choices to make personal
sacrifices it was said that when Martin
Luther King was invited to become the
head of the Montgomery
Association he didn't decline
immediately because he said let me think
about it he said that if he had really
thought about it for very long he would
have permanently declined but he
embraced the responsibility to make the
promise of the Constitution forever
larger generations for generations to
come and the course of modern history
was thereby changed when I have faced
difficult choices I've tried to remember
my mother's clear lines their
applicability to my contemporary life is
not always easy to frame and neither
will it be for those lines that you
divide and design and divide but this
every member is that she lived by her
values and her fervent belief that her
cause could be one but it may take time
it may even be painful but nothing of
value has been attained without struggle
so much is lost if we cannot summon the
courage of our convictions when there
are times that the way does not seem
clear for me I am comforted by the words
of the prophet Isaiah they who wait upon
the Lord shall renew their strength they
who wait upon the Lord shall renew their
strength in those instructions I believe
that the Prophet is saying that through
our patients regain strength they shall
mount up with wings of eagles they shall
one and not be weary life is not a
sprint it is a marathon they who wait
upon the Lord will gain strength they
shall run and not be weary and they
shall walk and not faint the doors of
opportunity have been opened wide
and as you enter make sure that it
matters that you were here on earth for
it is not the privilege which we are
born but what we make of our lives that
counts thank
good morning when it when I was asked to
give this family tribute I was stunned
as an engineering student I have not
written an academic paper for about six
months but don't worry I've been doing
other rigorous academic work I assure
you Dean Penn Maura and mom and dad
ironically as an engineering student
some of my most edifying assignments at
Columbia where some of the essays i
wrote i think it was primarily that i
put more time and caring to them than
the Kosta constant six problem sets ida
churn out each week on a sundry of
topics generally consisting of
differential calculus laplacian fourier
transforms electromagnetics
microelectronic circuits the physics of
solid-state semiconductor materials and
devices and computer programming many of
these do sound challenging that's why I
chose to list them
however there are many much more
challenging classes I've chosen to omit
because they would sound innocuous 21
not educated in the art finally I
thought it was funny that one would be
asked to reflect upon family at the very
zen at the ones independence as
responsibilities mount on the horizon
growing up you will meet and see many
people's families and you will begin to
notice similarities between them well I
can see continua T between my friends
families in mind there are clear
distinctions and as I grew older I
realized why I was different there's
almost a sense of belonging when I am
with my family the harbinger of this
realization can be some of the most
superficial things imagine standing out
and almost every crowd you ever stood in
imagine seeing Times Square in every
direction above the millions of revelers
during the New Year's Eve Ball drop the
only times I've felt exceptionally tall
or when I'm away from my family I would
not say I come from a typical family a
term I've always used to describe my
family is interesting I'm the second of
five children my father was an aerospace
engineer who went on to become a
corporate attorney my mother after a
long career as a registered nurse
decided to stay home and raise the
family my older brothers given name is
Alexander Hamilton salon / born the day
of the duel between Alexander Hamilton
and Aaron Burr
my given name is Thomas Edison slant
over I was born the day the light bulb
was invented and coincidentally I'm an
electrical engineer
my younger brother is given name is john
locke's lon over just because my dad
likes john locke
my mother named my sisters because if my
father did at least one of them would
have been named Margaret Thatcher
concerning family or life in general it
is my view as long as you're happy with
the person you are it was all for the
better and if not you have the power to
change that as we had tentatively left
our homes under the aegis of Columbia
University we began to form our own
microcosm of society in the tradition of
residential colleges beginning with
Oxford in the 11th century to imbue us
with the qualities which enable us to
become good citizens individuals or
leaders whatever happens to be the
dictum of the day it is self-evident
that the life of university student is
transitory however I do think it's
unique time in one's life and the
university environment has some
remarkable attributes when again will
you be living in a community where the
population is nominally of the same age
and of similar interest to you as a
child up until middle school I would
venture to guess your interpersonal
relationships were based on geography
and who your parents friends were since
then these elements have waned in
importance however as we leave
university life many of our new
day-to-day relationships will tend to be
a function of those we interact with on
a professional basis and again geography
after commuting to Columbia for a period
I decide to move on campus and upon
university housing I felt I just didn't
fit in with dorm life I was living in
schapiro 401 I was larger than the bed
in every dimension and could touch my
hand and foot the opposite walls at the
same time each summer during college I
worked as an engineer which enabled me
this year to live off campus for the
first time it was a bit frightening for
the first time I was truly living on my
own hang all my own bills however there
was a sense of pride at the end of the
day I could tell my parents were proud
of me and that our relationship had
changed one market change was that I
stopped receiving unsolicited advice via
the phone and my parents were asking my
mission in so much as they wouldn't tell
me what to do one night recently I took
an early weekend and went to a friend's
beach house during which my father
stayed in my apartment for one evening
upon returning every pet peeve of mine
of the house I grew up in appeared in my
home for instance a bar of Ivory soap
was opened in place by the sink where
there was one already in the shower
trade the only place i use it and i was
absolutely livid
as I sat down and thought about the
situation I thought to myself wow you
know my father had to put up with this
for 20 years and as a result I
understood him better furthermore when
my parents do something that bothers me
like growing grocery shopping for me and
buying food I do not eat or food I would
never have time to cook I know they have
good intentions I think of myself at six
years old with my siblings cooking my
mom a mothers day breakfast pancakes
eggs coffee the works my mom took only
two bites and we thought we did the
greatest thing ever growing up in a
Catholic family and as a Catholic I was
fortunate enough to have attended a
Franciscan High School which gave me a
great education and strong formation
periodically at the morning prayer they
would have a student read inspirational
words one particular day was Mother
Teresa's do it anyway which was read
which states people who are often
unreasonable irrational and
self-centered forgive them anyway if you
were kind people may accuse you of
selfish ulterior motives be kind anyway
if you were successful you will win some
unfaithful friends and some genuine
enemies succeed anyway if you're honest
and sincere people may deceive you be
honest and sincere anyway what you spend
years creating others could destroy
overnight create anyway if you find
serenity and happiness some may be
jealous be happy anyway the good you do
today will be forgotten do good anyway
will often be forgotten I'm sorry given
the best you give the best you have and
it will never be enough give your best
anyway in the final analysis it's
between you and God it was never between
you and them anyway anyway upon hearing
these inspirational words
I thought to myself you know what that's
great if you're mother Teresa however
recently I've come to realize that the
knowledge you can do something may be
more important than the evanescent
fruits of that labor well class of 2010
it's been great wherever life takes you
I wish you all the best and finally let
us thank our families for enabling us to
be here today
good good morning ah good morning
everyone I'd like to begin by extending
Salaam's to everyone in attendance as
many of you may already know Muslims
greet one another by stating assalamu
alaykum which means peace be upon you
it's customary to respond in kind by
saying walaikum assalaam which means
upon you be peace according to a series
of Google searches this customer roads
as a means of identifying friends in a
land where tribal warfare was a common
occurrence salam was a means of finding
friends among enemies and creating
community from individuals this greeting
United people regardless of their
previous affiliations and brought them
together under under a common faith
today Islam is the second largest
religion in the world but its members
can still find commonality in the simple
phrase standing here before you all a
little over four years since I tore up
in my admissions packet and proudly
wrote the words congratulations you have
been accepted to Columbia class of 2010
I have been invited to reflect on what
it is meant for me as a Muslim woman to
be a part of this community however this
proved to be more difficult than I had
anticipated because for me my experience
has not been defined by any one
characteristic or quality that
experience is something that is truly
unique to the community here at Columbia
and I hope that you will see why by the
end of my reflection we as students come
from all 50 states scores of countries
across the globe every socio-economic
strata dozens of religions and spiritual
affiliations and a spectrum of political
ideologies but to call this population a
melting pot would be to deny the
strength and vivacity of the smaller
micro communities that make up the
greater whole I would like you to i
would like to invite you to see this
campus the way that I see it so try to
imagine with me as you step onto the
campus through the gates at 116 let the
hustle and bustle of Broadway fade into
the background sunlight shines through
the trees along your path
and the cherry blossoms lying College
walk are an explosion of dusty pink
against the bright green of new spring
leaves faintly at first but growing
louder the further inward you walk are
the sounds of birds hidden somewhere in
the trees the first years chattering on
the way to their frontiers lecture drums
echoing across campus from the Missouri
performance on low Plaza these are the
sights and sounds that make up the
heartbeat of this campus they are part
of what makes Columbia the vibrantly
diverse place and dynamically said it is
I've worked with the admissions office
for all four years of my time at
Columbia and one of the biggest
questions that I'm asked from parents
who want to know how such a really
diverse campus community really interact
they say they see groups of students
sitting out in the steps on a sunny
afternoon and instantly take note of the
little clusters of white faces mobile
Custer's of brown faces and they grow
concerned do the different groups of
students ever clash they asked me and i
always respond absolutely we are
Columbia students after all from the
time we take our first steps onto campus
were bred to analyze and debate
previously held ideas while
simultaneously struggling to defend our
own convictions in our seminars we
ponder and dispute the great text that
we may or may not have read before class
but must have an opinion on regardless
these communities extend past the
classroom to the residence halls where I
represented Carmen 12 with all of my
heart the students those students those
parents all grouped together were more
likely to be there because they were in
the same class on the same team or on
the Executive Board of a cultural
political or Greek organization than
just because their faces happen to look
similar we are brought together in our
micro communities by deeper qualities
like our common interest experiences and
goals while these groups are unique in
their own right it is the times that
they intersect that the true Columbia
spirit emerges one of the most
polarizing events in our tenure here was
the arrival of Mahmoud Ahmadinejad in
the fall of 2007 there were just as many
of us who are outraged at his presence
as there were those who defended his
right to free speech in contemporary
civilizations we read the words of
Milton and Voltaire but the real meaning
of the
famous saying was being taught on the
giant screens projected onto south lawn
I may not approve of what you say but I
defend to the death your right to say it
perhaps the most impressive thing about
that day was the extraordinary level of
respect and character that we all showed
there were debates and rallies protests
and counter protests and counter counter
protests that made me wonder how many
Columbia students it really takes a
screw in a light bulb but at the end of
the day roommates standing on opposite
sides of the issue could get together to
discuss the day's events over dinner and
John Jay for me that is the kind of
connection that is invoked every time
someone gives Salam it's a show of peace
and goodwill regardless of affiliation
that ties the community together as we
prepare to leave the communities that
we've created here at Columbia we carry
the tools to forge these relationships
among the new people we meet never
forget the different communities that
we've been a part of in our time here
the different communities that we will
be a part of and intersect with and the
ways of thinking about an overcoming
conflict that we've developed these
qualities are what make us global
citizens of the Columbia community being
part of this community is unique and
that feeling at home at Columbia makes
you at home with the world thank
the thinker's engraved on the stones of
butler library have become a familiar
sight to us there are quiet but
intimidating community which ushered us
into our college years they challenged
me to read to think and most importantly
to act they insisted that we reach into
the literature of the past in order to
shape our lives and futures these days
the words of Micah the prophet speaks my
heart he's told you oh man what is good
and what the Lord requires of you only
to do justice to love mercy and to walk
humbly with your God Micah's charge is
directed towards the endurance
individual the search for justice mercy
and humility is ultimately the lonely
responsibility of every human being on
earth however it is impossible to pursue
these goals alone at Columbia I've
learned that the impact of justice
righteousness and humility is more
powerful when a community strives for
them together the power of numbers and
multiplicity of identity yield great
results in this world the question is
how to find community is it in the
library in class we have spent countless
hours in the library we have pored
through books and read hundreds of pages
we've connected with each other over
ideas and we've connected with
civilizations and communities through
the collective memories of history we
have found that the journey through
college has not just been an academic
one the classroom is only the seed of
education we have learned to translate
knowledge and theory into practice only
by engaging the different layers of
communities here on campus when I
entered Barnard College community for me
was defined by the Syrian Jewish
community in which I was raised growing
up my identity was formed by
synagogue school and camps within days
of my arrival at Barnard my first year
dorm Sol's were you two became my
community the circles of pillow Yama
alternative spring break and SGA added
layers to my identity on campus at
Columbia my communities overlap and
interlocked over the course of a single
day I live in many circles some are
intimate and some are vast some circles
are homogeneous based on culture and
religion and others unite a diverse
group of individuals committed
passionately to a cause as in Take Back
the Night some of my communities merged
and some of them clashed the beauty of a
place like Columbia is that it helps us
combine all of these identities and
reach out to broader communities this
may be the only time in our lives when
so many different parts of our
identities coexist under one roof the
Columbia Barnard hello echoes this theme
it houses a wide range of religious
cultural political and social groups the
craft center is a home for religious
development for social justice advocacy
for torah study I go to crack for prior
services to hear a great lecture and to
have a good time Columbia has allowed me
to live a life with many layers the
facets of identity were constantly in
flux moving with the ebb and flow of my
life it took some time to adjust to the
multiplicity that had become my life at
Barnard an adjustment that I shared with
many of my classmates and through which
and made many of my friends at college
learning how to juggle communities was
an integral part of my four-year journey
at college forgiveness flexibility and
creativity were vital parts to this
process these qualities help me
permanently incorporate these different
layers into my identity which I hope to
nurture beyond my time at Columbia
community has the power to nurture it
can also be dangerously isolate
community inspires our own growth but
may keep us isolated from humanity most
recently we as Columbia students were
called upon to mobilize as a community
and reach out to the people of Haiti
when the earthquake struck we were on
winter break the students of Columbia
University were dispersed throughout the
world president Bollinger emailed the
student body reminding us that we are
part of the community of humanity we
came together to mobilize and to send
help the response on campus was
overwhelming communities are created in
moments of shared historical memory
uniting people who live three events and
experiences the election of Barack Obama
last year created such a community as I
ran out of my building that night I was
overwhelmed by the emotional commotion
on the streets I remember the deep sense
of connection in our neighborhood
together students our neighbors and
morningside heights and the rest of New
York City forge of a memory of this
enormous moment in American history
community building is not always
seamless for a week the joint coalition
between hello and the Columbia College
seas Office of Multicultural Affairs
became part of a community in New
Orleans affected by Hurricane Katrina we
formed our own community based on the
values of social justice and
multiculturalism while learning about
the people we would be joining in New
Orleans the joining of communities in
tell too many hours of identity
exploration we pushed to think through
and beyond the multiple facets of
ourselves we spent the months before and
the week of spring break trying to
understand New Orleans and the impacts
of Katrina it was vital to understand
what it meant to be a part of that
community when we arrived we stretched
our hearts to appreciate the unique
realities of their lives for a week we
did service work and try to make a
difference in this corner of the world
as I think back to the philosophers of
butler library I wonder what do they
think of the class of 2010 with our
laptops and our diversity we've created
a new community incubating our
identities
they have watched over us for four years
the writings of challenged us and we
have grappled with applying their ideas
to a new world together with the prophet
Micah they asked us to make the world a
better place I'm intimidated by these
expectations however I know that our
time here will serve as good preparation
and that our community here will always
serve as a backbone to support us in the
future I would like to take this moment
to thank my family my friends my
teachers and mentors thank you for an
incredible four years of learning and
laughter tears and everything in between
to mom dad Sara avaya kavi and mortified
by constant sources of support through
this challenging and exciting adventure
called life and to Micah my number one
fan I cannot thank you all enough
congratulations to all
let us stand for a moment of silence and
in this moment of silence I ask that you
think of those things for which you are
grateful think of those people to whom
you are grateful and give God thanks
amen
let us sing together our recessional hem
which is printed on your program yellow
my motto
Oh
ha
hey
you